[Music]
hey there and welcome to this
lesson on motion tracking 2d and 3d as
well as stabilization within after
effects i'm cameron
i'm your instructor and we are going to
start
this series of lessons with
the 2d tracker and what is the 2d
tracker well the 2d tracker is very
powerful it's been inside of after
effects for many many many years
and it can track things
inside your footage so that you can
apply things to your footage to make
them look more interesting so in this
particular case we are going to apply
some interesting looking graphics
to this footage right here
i'll go ahead and preview this and we're
going to do about three seconds of it
so you can get an idea but this is just
some
footage of a maple leaf shot
and it's interesting because it actually
goes out of focus right here
it's in focus goes out of focus which
can cause havoc on tracking sometimes so
it'll be interesting to see what happens
on this one
what else is interesting about this is
that the leaf actually bends upwards so
here it's pretty flat and it bends
towards the camera and it also because
the wind is blowing on it it has a
little bit of a fluctuation in it
which tells me that we need to track a
few different things
so
in general when you're tracking
motion inside of after effects
you can track a few different ways
with a few different techniques
what you have to do to track is you
always have to double click your footage
down here in the timeline or up here in
the project window to open up the layer
window so you're not able to track
here within our composition window
so we just go down here to our timeline
double click
and that opens up this layer
as you can see here it says layer maple
leaf so it opens up the footage in the
layer
window here's our composition here's our
layer window
something else to keep in mind is it's
always best to be full res
when you're tracking so we'll make sure
we're on full resolution here
and we're going to
just track about three seconds maybe
we'll track a little bit longer we'll
see
so we'll go back into our layer footage
here
and when we track as i mentioned just
previously
you can track different things you can
track position
you can track scale and you can track
rotation when working with the 2d
tracker
so all we have to do to track is
go up here there's four different
buttons and we will cover all these
buttons but 2d tracking
is track motion
so
our
motion source is our layer footage which
is here
so that's all good and we don't need to
mess with any of this stuff yet i'll
show you in just a second what happens
so with our footage selected here we're
at the layer window here we select track
motion
and boom some options pop up here we
also have a tracker that shows up down
here
so we'll start with just a very simple
track and you can see that it defaults
to the position track so when we add
things like rotation
or scale
there's additional track points added
but because we're working with just
position we only need one track point
added to begin with
so what we're going to do is we want to
hover over this track point and you can
see as i kind of move over it the
the cursor changes to a move tool back
to the cursor
back to the move tool and then here we
have like a little anchor point
thing that pops up here right so if i
was to click and drag this
little plus sign here it's going to move
it wherever i could put it in the layer
window but what we want to do is we want
to make sure that we're just inside this
outer box
and click and that way we're dragging
the entire
box if i let go you can see it's got the
outer box the inner box and the plus
symbol so again i'm going to track click
just inside here i'm going to drag and
you can see that it zooms in on our
footage here
okay so i want to find a good point
that i can track and maybe
this little black spot you can see a
little bit of black right there it's
always good to have as much contrast as
possible when tracking it's also
a good idea that i find to expand the
boxes just slightly
you don't have to depending on what your
footage is the bigger this box is
expanded the more the after effects is
going to look
at the surrounding footage to calculate
a track so the essentially the bigger
this box is
the longer the track time is going to
take
so i typically with tracking here in 2d
motion it's
sometimes trial and error to get a good
track
back over here in our track window and i
should mention if you don't see this
window you need to go up here to your
window
tracker to make sure that the tracker
is a pop-up it's the panel's open and
you can see it so
i just happened to have it open and i
brought it over here a lot of times
it'll show up on the right side here
so again here we are in the tracker
window there are some options here we're
going to mess with edit target in a
minute
options
click that you're going to see it says
it's tracker one it's using the built-in
tracker
sometimes via mocha it'll ask if you
want to use mocha or if you have a
third-party tracking system it may ask
if you want to use that
um i
a lot of times defaults to luminance
i think on maybe this one i had
saturation i got a better track
uh but by default it's always going to
be luminance subpixel positioning i
believe is on and this is all default
material so for whatever reason i had
saturation selected
um sometimes if i'm having a very hard
time tracking i'll
try checking these different boxes to
see if things improve sometimes they do
sometimes they don't the 2d tracker
inside of after effects is very
temperamental i'll just say that
so we're on our settings
uh
we have analyze okay analyze this means
analyze one frame back
analyze backwards just if you click this
it's like playing backwards it's going
to analyze backwards so for whatever
reason we started our cursor here at
three seconds and that's where we found
our tracking point we could analyze
backwards this way and we could also
analyze forwards this way i just happen
to be starting at zero you don't have to
start at zero
again clicking here it says analyze
forward it's just going to play through
it and
this button is analyzed one frame
forward so it's going to go one frame at
a time if you're having a really tricky
track you may have to analyze one frame
at a time and reposition the tracker if
that's the case so um
let's actually just click one frame
forward
and we can see it's still on the track
seems to be doing okay
so a lot of times what i'll do and you
can see the keyframes are being added
down here on the timeline so i'm going
to go ahead and hit
analyze sometimes it can move very
quickly
and you can see it quickly
gets off track so let's go ahead and do
that
and this one's actually doing pretty
good
oh there it goes
so you can see there it jumped off so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
back up here
and i'm just going to
use page down on my keyboard
to find when that track
loses itself which is right there
so
the little black speck that we were
following before
is pretty much gone at this point so
it's almost it is it's a matter of
eyeing it to make sure
okay does that look right back a frame
forward or frame yeah it looks about
right
so let's go ahead and move this one
and i'll just go back and forth and kind
of make sure they look okay
again this these are way off so i'm
going to click on my timeline down here
i'm going to hit u and i'm just going to
go ahead and delete these keys here
so
back up here in our window and back up a
frame you can see it's kind of that's
where it should be
and it jumps all the way down here so we
should be back up in here
looks about right
like i said it doesn't have to be
perfect a lot of times you can cheat and
get away with some things
so we're out of key frames here so let's
go ahead and track forward one frame
and then again see it's because it's
going out of focus it's having a really
hard time
so this is a very tricky track
i love that word tricky track uh but it
seems to be doing okay now i could just
uh click play again and move forward but
because this is so
uh tricky right now i'm just going to do
it frame by frame and make sure
things just now see it's getting
questionable right there
i think it needs to go up just a hair
there's our black spot
and
yep
okay let's try forward
okay so there we are we're three seconds
into it
i think we've got an okay track and
let's just uh
let me show you how you would apply this
uh just for this particular example we
are going to use
um a graphic so let me pull that in real
quick here
so i've got my graphic in here this is
from a a
digital pack that motion science sells
and i'm by no means saying that you need
to buy this but uh i'm gonna use this
for an example so when we have a
a tracked piece of footage like we have
here
we could apply this track directly to
these to the footage here
and if i jump back in the composition
you're gonna see if i turn this on there
it is and i back it up you're going to
see here is the piece of footage i want
to track into the shot
and you could apply the tracking data to
this footage directly but a much smarter
way to approach this
is to apply the tracking data to a null
object
so we need to create a new
null object
and there's our null object and we're
going to make sure that we're back here
in the layer panel
if you're in the composition panel like
this you can see i can't
access any of this tracking data for
whatever reason i have to go back into
my layer window from here
i have my tracked data but i haven't
applied it to anything it's just a
tracking data that's sitting down here
um
on my timeline and something i should
point out is you can also see right here
in the confidence
that's how confident it is on the track
right so
somewhere in here we get down to 82
percent saying ah this may not be a good
track
81 not so great typically if you go
below 80 you need to re-analyze
and there we go 70 i think that's where
i started tracking it myself
uh because we got down to 70 so now
we're back to 100 confidence it's saying
hey i got this right so something to
keep in mind is to look at that uh here
we're 100
quite a while 98 99 saying hey i got it
pretty good
so
anyways now we need to apply our
tracking data
here
to a null object
so we need to go up to edit target
and we need to select our null object
and there's our old and you see some
other things here i have some things
hidden on my timeline uh from some tests
i did so if you see you know you see in
a second nolan you're saying where is
that on the timeline it's hidden right
so don't even don't even think about
that stuff don't look at that stuff so
here we are we've selected null object
three it's layer two we're gonna say
okay
so that's our target and now we want to
apply
our tracking data to that so we hit
apply and it's gonna pop up and say okay
do you wanna apply it to the x and y or
to x only or y only typically you're
going to be applying it to x and y
um i don't know that i've ever actually
applied just to x or y only maybe on a
few occasions
yes apply it click ok
and you're going to see
that the null object here
now
has the data applied to it right
so if i turn off this footage here
you can see there's our knoll and it's
just moving right along with that leaf
looks really nice right so it's track to
it it's looking great so now what i can
do is i can go back to my digi square
and i can say hey i want this digi
square to recognize this null data and
follow that null
and the easy way to do that is just to
parent and the trick is to hold down
shift so if i just say
parent to the null
nothing changed the digi square didn't
move
it is tracked to that
but it's not taking on like the rotation
that kind of stuff
if i [ __ ] hold down shift and then
parent watch what happens to my digi
square
it moves right up there where i need it
to be
and i'm going to change the mode to
screen
and there it is
right so if i preview this
there it is awesome
so it looks pretty cool and if i was
just doing a single point track this
would work right but i want to make it
look even more interesting i wanted to
take on the rotation of the of the leaf
i wanted to take on the scale because
the scale does slightly change as that
leaf comes towards the camera okay so if
this was a completely flat shot
a one point track is all we need if
we're maybe the camera's moving across
these leaves or up and down
the leaves aren't moving it's completely
flat a one-point track will do us
justice but for this particular case we
want to do a more detailed track
and to do that
we need to track position rotation and
scale so what we're going to do is we're
going to leave this on screen but we're
going to turn off
our transfer mode we're going to go
ahead
we're going to transfer mode we're going
to reset our position
we're gonna just go ahead and
get rid of all this data in here
we'll leave our null here
and actually we'll just change the name
of this to tracking null
so now we're going to go back into our
footage and we're going to track for
position scale and rotation and upon
looking at this closer i can tell that
the
initial track point here at the top
uh is not quite right
so i am going to
delete that
and we're just going to start brand new
so we're going to say track motion we
want to track the position the rotation
and the scale because
this leaf has a
motion where it kind of pops up from
like this anchor point here and kind of
bends towards
the camera
and we can simulate that with some scale
so we're going to track all three
and we're also going to go into our
options and we're going to say that we
want to
stop tracking if the confidence is below
80
so
this means that
after effects will stop tracking the
motion if the confidence of the track on
either one of these points goes below 80
so we're gonna say okay
and let's zoom in here and let's go
ahead and move track point
two right here
and we're going to expand the outer box
and we'll expand the
smaller box and let's move this track
point
to a different point maybe
let's try this little guy right here
and i held down the space bar to move
up here in the footage i'm going to take
the box here expand
box a little bit expand this one
and we've got both track points and
we're going to go ahead and click
analyze forward and if the confidence on
either one of these drops below 80
percent it should stop
and there we go so there it stopped
and if i open
this up
tracker 1 and tracker 2. uh confidence
on tracker 1 got to 63.9 tracker 2 73.2
if i do page up we're at 87 and 82
91 and 80
80 88 okay so
pretty much right here
we need to fix both track points so
let's
back up
and i like to just kind of look at
what's going on here so it looks like a
lot of motion blur all of a sudden
stepped in
and that's probably what's throwing us
off
and
back up one frame
forward
that seems okay
maybe in there and we'll move forward
another frame and you can see this is
where it really starts to get lost i'm
going to stay on this first tracking
point here
and
try and get it figured out here
hey i can see it's very blurry
which again is going to throw off the
track
so i might try there and just see if it
can pick up a track
actually there's still a lot of motion
blur going on so we're going to go back
into here
and just doing this all by hand and it
should work out okay
let me just back it up here
there's just a lot of motion blur
there looks like maybe it's slowed down
a bit
so i'm going to go ahead and back up
here
and
go down here to the second track point
and you can see it's really off there
so it should be up in here
so let's go ahead and just hit
zoom out a little bit here and let's go
ahead and track forward and see what
happens
again this top point
kind of got out of whack
and there's no
right way to do this it's just whatever
works
and there we go so we made it through
the rest of our track i only want to go
to three seconds
and it looks like
everything ended up tracking okay
uh what i'm gonna do is zoom in here and
just
go through this and make sure it looks
yeah
definitely on the second point here it
works
let's focus a little bit more on the
track one make sure we're
good to go here
yeah that works for me
so we're going to back out and we're
going to make sure our target is set to
tracking null tracking null layer two is
our target okay and let's go ahead and
apply
the x and y
okay
and there we go
and now our tracking null has position
scale and rotation all applied to it so
by holding down shift and the parent
pick whip
the digisquare anchor point right here
is going to be parented to the null
center anchor point and boom there we go
and now
because i parented the digisquare to the
null and there's no anchor point data
there's no position data there's no
scale data
or rotation data i can easily open up my
digisquare and i can position it
how i
want it to be
somewhere right there i'm going to scale
it up just a little bit
so it covers the entire leaf
and maybe just rotate it
just a little bit and let's play it back
and see how it looks
i think it looks pretty cool i dig it
that is motion tracking with position
scale and rotation inside of after
effects
let's move on
[Music]
you